foreign
[Music]
cast number 15. today we are honored to
have with us a guest that I've known for
a short 54 years Ron Owens
and I went through training group
together in 1967 a company at the
special forces training group he joins
us today to talk not only about our time
together in training group which I think
will minimize but our time and SOG
together and the different aspects of
life and then the fascinating time
thereafter Ron welcome to the show
brother thank you appreciate it amen
Airborne all right all the way indeed so
uh for our listening audience uh I want
to say
we go into podcast number 15 courtesy of
Jocko bullying Productions and we thank
him for helping us to do all this and to
move forward and to capture our history
of which you are a vital part sir thank
you can't wait to meet him indeed Monday
he'll be here all right and Airborne so
um
again uh I arrived at a company
um 1967 May after jump school and at
some point you rolled in the a company
we were together there with spider Parks
Rick Howard a few other yes art Russell
our dress class right and the Frenchman
rolled in there about the same time it
was a little bit later I think a little
bit but a little bit but anyways he was
on a good team exactly and then um so we
met there and then
um we at the end of our training
we had the FTX yep and uh that was
December so it failed a field training
exercise they called it which is the
Final Phase yes I don't think called we
didn't call it Robin sage then no it's
called Butler words I think is that
right gobbler Woods God that's it cover
one so FTX the final training where
after everybody does their MOS training
they all come together as an A-Team you
jump into a Target at night in our case
we jumped at night in the rain at 500
feet wow which was the first and then we
landed and of course we had some of our
brothers we had Jim Mitchell had a
broken leg we heard him screaming in the
trees and another guy had a broken back
I forget who that was
but that was our operational training
then we went TDY before we landed in
Vietnam yeah and then for near sir after
that FTX and whereupon we earned our
Green Berets yes sir
what happened to you after that point
because that's where we diverged yeah
and then we came together again in
Vietnam like magic well I heard they
were shooting at people over there so I
I promptly got assigned to the seventh
group
and during that period I still didn't
fully understand where I was heading or
what I was about to get into indeed but
none of us did I know there was a
sergeant major back in those days by the
name of TJ gray and he found out that I
spoke a little bit of German so he said
where you need to go is to my Gabriel
team and I said oh okay what's a Gabriel
team very good
so I did and I spent about our listing
audience that the Gable team was well
the Gabriel team was a demonstration
team
that demonstrated what the capabilities
of a Oda operation of Detachment Alpha
could do at 12 men The 12-man A Team had
two officers and 10 enlisted at that
time and what they did was that they
didn't demonstrated each of the Moses
the military occupation Specialties
they would demonstrate that not only in
English but they were demonstrated in a
chosen language that they were
proficient in
and so my little skit took all of about
30 seconds about the extent of my
journaling too but they uh they would
they would sit there and the people
would come through there would be
congressmen there would be important
people that were coming in and they were
seeing where the funding would go for
this new stand-up organization called
Green Berets and also let me interrupt
you for a second the most famous Gabriel
team demonstration which was back in 61
or 62 yes with um our general meeting
with JFK yes and after that meeting JFK
designated by executive order the
official rearing of the Green Beret
which before that the regular army had
opposed yes but JFK who we loved and
respect ever since regardless of any
politics yes was our president gave us
the honor so move on to that Gabriel
team he saw the demonstration was
impressed and general Yarbrough said hey
by the way when you go back could you
make this official and he did yeah so
I'm sorry to interrupt but God no that's
that's good it's a good reminder it jogs
my memory too indeed but I I finished
that and then of course Mrs Alexander uh
wasn't going to have anything of me
staying back there being on a
demonstration team when all of you guys
had already beat me over there so I
ended up uh coming over in August to
Vietnam and I went to uh and just for
our listeners yes this is the first time
they've ever listened to a sogcast miss
is Billy Alexander worked at a pentagon
and her one of her sole jobs was
assigning Green Berets young in nature
like yourself two
yes Vietnam
[Laughter]
she is to me the Godmother indeed oh
yeah yeah and she was beautiful oh my
gosh a lovely lady absolutely one of our
Saints yes exactly so you go down Billy
get you there everybody got me there I
flew into Cameron Bay I thought it was
very Scenic and then when the Heat hit
and I got off that plane uh that changed
my attitude pretty quick you did you
feel like you had to cut through the
humidity yeah yeah
indeed yes uh they should have never air
conditioned that cabin and
we got off and we spent about one night
there uh all of a sudden somebody showed
up in the sterile uniform and said
you're coming with us to a place called
natrang and I said okay and so we went
to nutrang we checked in there and they
were waiting on us to to go to a combat
orientation course and the train was the
fifth Special Forces Group headquarters
at that time that is correct this is
August 1968. that is correct and that
near the middle of August the early
property if then you had to do your own
country training before things got dicey
oh no well we from there we went
straight to a set of holding barretts
our Barracks were directly next to the
rocondo company and uh so they had did
some interviews and did some uh they did
their physicals they checked us in and
they gave us some miraculous little guns
the I forget what they were they were
World War II I think or maybe one the
carbines the Caribbeans yes yes yes
that's it being a weapons man I should
have remembered that shouldn't I but uh
anyway we they have a scorpions and we
did guard Duty we did uh uh different
types of assignments that they would
give us and then of course uh
a few days later we would go down and we
would go to a place called hantray
Island as says which we did the COC
course right and uh so when I got to
Andrei Island I was assigned to a bunch
of guys and we all picked out little
miniature teams that we were on
and then the excitement began because
then they ran us down these jungle
trails with pop-up targets and out of
trees and on the ground
and uh evidently I must have done pretty
well because the instructor came up to
me and said your next assignment is
rocondo school and I said great I said
uh not knowing what rocondo school was
yeah but anyway
uh he said yes that's what's going to
happen he says and as soon as you get in
here
unbeknownst to me I did not know what
had happened at the camp all right this
is August around August 23rd 1968 just I
was there just I was about August
at the camp
and so what ended up happening then is
that we finished up the the course and
they said okay this is what it is and
they said all right Owens this is where
you're gonna go
and we said where's that and he said
well we can't really tell you just yet
we have to make sure it's your security
clearance is okay
I know I didn't know I have to have a
security clearance but but I do and so
and so we were there for like two days
and in the meantime we would fall out in
the morning to do pt with the recondo
company yeah guys and there was uh it
was really confusing because I didn't
understand I thought it was American but
there was all these Koreans that were
there with us really oh man the Rocks
they were hard as rocks too absolutely
and they were I mean they would do put
if they saw you doing a push-up they'd
do six more than what you would do this
is a royal Army a royal order of Korea
yes The Rock The Rock oh my God those
guys were amazing unbelievable and so we
did that and then uh
they called us
about August 24th or 25th and said this
is your class date this is when you're
going to book you know be starting
the very next day they came in and and
pulled the guys that they had selected
that thought would run the jungle trail
out on the island pretty well and said
we need to know if you'd like to go to
okay a place called fob4
and I said sure why not they said well
they just took some major casualties and
they need help now not yesterday but now
and I said okay and they said all right
I said we'll go out and grab your
rucksack because it's already packed for
you they had already made that decision
really
took it
put me on on a huey along with five or
six other guys
and off we went and we got into the camp
uh
just for the record we're talking about
fob forward
CCN and this is uh August 68 at the time
there are six fobs and that were all
part of the secret War that's from
before Da Nang was just north of marble
Mountain which we'll talk more about a
little bit but first so you land at the
helicopter pad yeah on that what day was
it do you remember uh
because the attack was uh the morning of
August 23rd it was the art the the three
days four days
three or four days shortly the year
after okay that's what I did yeah well I
landed indeed and and you know and I got
off it was it was it was a
it was a
a surreal type of feeling at the the
place was very quiet where normally you
would hear a lot of sounds and you would
see we didn't land at the at the helipad
and on the end we actually landed down
there was a bee company uh further down
the road right just down the road we
landed there and the guy picked us up
and a three-quarter ton with no markings
black deep okay and we jumped in and he
said this is some weapons I said yeah I
said well here take what you want and he
had a bunch of M16s and things like that
and so we took those and we said he said
and if we take any fire
coming into this place he said just
shoot
it says I'll keep driving you keep
shooting
so we drove down and came through the
main gate and drove down past the
helipad pulled up out front of the
headquarters got out
and sergeant major
Charlie Vickers oh yeah Charlie Vickers
came up and said okay this is it and he
says okay I see this and he said are you
mad already and he said
uh okay and he said Owens I said yes
sergeant major he said I see that you're
a medic and I said no I'm just I'm not
even a half I'm a half medic and that's
another story but he said all right well
never mind he says uh I want you to go
to the dispensary and he said just take
you back and I was going I I you know
the type of thing that's stuttering yeah
off I went over there then we had some
guys that had been wounded in the attack
but In fairness to you are listens
Michael Ron Owens what is a half medic I
mean I know the answer to that question
but please explain why this part of your
unique history well
actually the MOs by the time I got to
where
you were at yeah well I was up in fob4 I
was a uh radio operator
but before that I had went to I was a
medic assigned to a medic school yeah
and back at Fort Bragg up on smoke bomb
Hill so there's a uh a bunch of a war or
two Barracks next to that was where
Womack hospital was located
and so then it was uh the 91 series
which is the medical series that usually
had a preface of 4S attached to the end
of it right and so what ended up
happening there was that I went through
the medical
basic aintments course on steroids okay
it's the same thing that you get if you
were 82nd Medicare but this one had the
very first level but again on steroids I
finished that I was getting ready to go
to Fort Sam Houston because that was the
next place that you had to go to learn
about your medications and some some
which is part of that time the Medics
course was about a year long at that
time yeah it ever bet yeah and it's
still the best medic training in the
world yesterday even though you're a
part of that yeah well for a short time
for a short time so when I I got ready
to go I know I had about another
24 maybe 48 hours and then I got the
word uh
that my wife
at that time
had come down with pleurisy and so I was
out I was actually kind of like an
isolation type of thing getting ready to
go out there
so the Red Cross notified them so then I
said pleurisy now I'm a medic I'm
supposed to know what that means
I had no idea what that meant you know
yeah so they pulled me they pulled me
out of that training and so come to find
out they had to put her in a it's kind
of a
exaggerated pneumonia type of position
right and they put her in a full body
cast so they could help control her
breathing and things like that
so I said okay so I had a about a
two-week vacation and I got all fast and
I was you know moping and groping and
trying to get everything's done
and finally her mother showed up to help
take care of her
so I reported back out to training group
and tried to find out if I could get
into that class and they said no you've
already missed some critical to the next
cycle
well the next cycle wasn't going to be
until like six months away
and I just went off the deep end I said
then I was sitting there around and
raving at some young E34 you know
sitting there with and I said okay
well there was a guy named Paul
villarosa Paul villarosa walked by and
he was a Como instructor instructor
Legendary Legendary Beret Commerce oh my
God yes yes yes we've talked about him
in earlier podcast oh did you good yeah
oh yeah yes unbelievable and I've first
hand witnessed how good he was you know
oh yeah oh yeah so anyway he came up and
he said Owens
he said are you going to sit there and
cry all day or do you want to go to
training I said training he reached over
and told us to put that man in my my
Como class at 1300 today that was at
zero nine he said now go find some place
to you know catch a nap get you
something to eat and be up there and
come on can do
I never looked back oh my God no kidding
there it is so that that's my half medic
story that led me to yeah
so anyway so there you are you arrive at
fob Ford and at that point you're a
combo geek as a combo geek but Charlie
Vickers needed a medic and he wherever
he could get one he's going to grab it
if you're Half Men that's right even if
I have met him so I he stuck me over
into the dispensary over by the motor
Pit by close to there yeah so as I walk
in I look up and there's the Honor
Graduate of the class that we were in
George bacon George Washington bacon III
that's him that's the man oh my God yeah
and he looks up and he goes big O what
are you doing here I said I'm a half
medic he said you're no damn medic I
said tell Charlie Victor's head
yeah I told him the story he said well
here grab his bedpan and grab this and
do this and so we shuffled around there
for two or three days and then that time
we would go out and we'd help you know
pull guard Duty and and it unbeknownst
to me George
I don't know where he came from I think
he came from Contin and how he ended up
fob one yeah he came there and I think
he was there for something but he got
shot through the shoulder and when he
got into the attack exactly August 23rd
exactly yes sir yep and came out of his
armpit and uh so he said yo I've been
wounded and so we're okay so he said do
you want to go run Recon I said
anything's to get me out of the
dispensary he said well come on so he
went down he picked us out a hooch he
went and talked to whoever the commander
was at that time
Colonel Warren yeah well Carl Warren
that's right he's a CEO that's right and
sure
um you know somebody else some some
captain or major I think he had he had
talked maybe it was a Recon company
Captain that's what I'm talking about
okay I forget who that was yeah I do too
because I still at F will be one when
you're down there at F will be four
right yes sir okay sure so anyway we
ended up and we got this the team
assignment and then the thing was is
that everything was really busy let me
back up to the day I got into Camp there
were things still smoking
this building's still smoking okay
several days after the attack yes
several days after the attack
they had
temporarily taken some
Dug Dug some some Graves over by one of
the crappers over towards were the
things just to put in some of the bodies
until they could come and find out what
they're going to do with them you know
transfer them someplace do an evaluation
so I said okay but anyway I I helped uh
do that and then George
bacon
then started putting together a team
but the problem was is that they were
all the teams that were that were real
active and was still really good
uh you don't you don't really jump in
and they didn't
we call something called strap hangers
sure and we were looking we were ready
to go help but they were busy with and
they didn't have time to train to get in
to blend in with what it is and of
course they would look at me okay and
they'd look at George and he's kind of
Slender you know big shoulders but
slender yes right and uh
so George was still continuing and so we
pressed on right there and it took a
little time for us to get enough people
together just to develop a team and
start training and that's where we had
to you had to recruit something digital
yards or Vehicles they were yards yeah
they were yards and uh they
there was some type of conflict and uh
with trying to get the yards if other
teams were one of the Yards and so those
guys had priority over this that the guy
who had my Recon team was Sidewinder it
there was a team there was a team
Sergeant there already at that halftime
uh head Sidewinder and I apologize got I
knew his name but I can't think of it
the second he'll come back but he he was
in the last days of rotating out and he
was there when the camp got hit short
timer short timer and then another
reason why you had a hard time getting
Monty yards or any troops right was it
from the attack we had many indigenous
our business personnel as along with the
16 Green Berets that were killed that
night yeah which is still a historic
high in SF history yes but our
counterparts took worse castles yes
coming to defend the camp and so when
you're trying to put together a team
within a week after that attack
uh finding good trained indigenous
troops was difficult because there's
always a vetting process first and then
finding them and getting people that are
going to stand up and work with you so
that was part of your challenge that was
it ask them well moving forward sir from
RT Sidewinder there you go so where we
were uh with regards to
training George would leave and again
maybe went back to fubai fubai he came
up yeah right he might went back but he
came back up and I was I was just I was
there by myself
and George was fluent in a couple of the
languages uh brew and raw day he had
picked up almost like instantly well
yeah he came to fubai he had picked
these languages yes like you and I would
be we need an interpreter yeah but
George was so brilliant oh he was he was
smart yeah very good but he anyway then
I became
ad hoc with our team sure and we would
try to do so uh when some teams
they didn't really run too many things
but but when they did they ran them
primarily out of fubai and Quan tree
right and so they if they needed
something like bright light or something
they would take some of the experience
guys so then they'd fly them up to there
well I did have the opportunity to get
on part of a stand-up bright light team
and went up to fubai and and stood by
for a couple days and it wasn't
necessary we didn't have to they they
somehow got Jolly Greens in to get the
team out and flew him
back to Fubar back to wherever they flew
into might have been nkp I'm not sure
but at any rate they I came back and
when I came back
and that was in
with the for about the middle of
September and then we still were trying
to think Georgia came back so we started
putting together a team
and he had some guys that that he had
set up I don't I don't know exactly
where he got them but I didn't really
care I was just glad to see him yeah and
so we did our first mission was up on
monkey mountain and so we did our
training Mission up there and uh the
there was uh
there was the usual stories about
monkeys attacking and things like that I
could hear them shaking the trees at
night for that's for sure well did you
ever have that well that's also the
experience where you're in the jungle
yeah you hear something coming towards
you and your first reaction is right via
Kong NBA because this is monkey mountain
which is just North of of
fob4 yes off into the challenge see yeah
training ground that and many of our
teams had contact there and we had
people get wounded a couple Kias quote
training so there you are and you can
hear something coming towards you your
first reaction oh the poker fact is
tight depends about a hand grenade and
you're attacked by uh monkeys big
evil mean spitting monkeys odorous yeah
yeah you could hear them they'll make it
all kinds of things obviously the
Vietcong Vietnam I think so yeah indeed
I think they've been recruited
but we we got up and we moved uh we
moved a couple clicks the next day and
they said okay that's enough of that so
they X filled us out and then we came
back
and then the next uh mission that I got
a chance for almost another training
Mission and it was up near a high Fong
pass and there were some roads and stuff
it went back in there and they were
trying to figure out if if there was any
movement that was up in that area
somebody had reported it so we went up
there and we stayed for three days and
uh we watched some
um
there was a movie out called air America
if you ever saw that movie or not oh
yeah oh yeah well they flew one of those
planes and landed up the side of a
mountain
I actually saw something like that
happen no you got that fluid in the
fluid up and it went straight up a
mountain it stopped some guys ran out of
the thing grabbed it
and tied off the tail uh
the the last little hook there the hook
yeah and then this guy gave it the left
Rudder right Rudder spun the plane
around and they still held it while they
offloaded uh the supplies on the other
side now to this day I don't know who
that was but I saw holy smokes and I
said George should we report something
he said no I don't think we should
report that I said okay but uh they were
they were there so that was that was
that was uh my second and then the third
one we went back to monkey mountain uh
and then a couple uh of short ones as we
got into October we came in with a guy
named sanderfield Allen Jones Sandman
Sandy Sandy came in and he was the one
two I was the one one and George
obviously was the one zero
and we had picked up two more
uh indigenous and now I want to say
that they were Vietnamese which I found
to be odd working directly with mountain
yards sure and so
that was just my impression
um we would sometimes go over to where
the log houses were and they would have
food we would sit and trying to eat with
them
but they they very rarely ever came over
to where we were at in the Recon company
right
um
what's the next thing I was going to say
about that is that
is the well your team was getting typed
I thought yeah well we're starting we're
starting to get ready yeah this is an
this is in October and that's pretty
much where we were at that point George
disappeared again
so we didn't all then I got real
familiar with marble Mountain
because the team we couldn't run George
was gone so we ended up pulling security
Duty I'm like you'd go on for a week and
you'd be off for a week for a week for a
week oh so we go for a week and really
it was kind of a blessing because you
didn't you didn't have Charlie Vickers
or somebody running around saying what
are you doing but we would run our own
patrols up on the top of the mountain
and that's where we discovered the caves
and the different things that were up
there and again marble Mountain there
are several Peaks I forget how many but
there's a couple underneath which the
Viet Cong had prepared for the uh at
least a year before the attacked on
August 23rd 68. you're right there was
still communist elements residual there
we never realized or at least I didn't
yeah in terms of retelling the story
that under marble Mountain there were
caves Trails several levels of activity
and so you're there and now you're
patrolling and you're learning more
about the inner workings of marble
Mountain yes which was
um a sanctuary yes for the Communists
that were right next to fob4 our base
that had just been attacked with one of
the most historic devastating attacks in
our history yes
and then
years later I'll I'll just throw this
out when we come back to it later but
but I went back to Vietnam with a couple
of my friends
and we went back this is like
eight nine ten years ago
we went back and we at the mountain
and then the base of that mountain uh
there was a village selling marble and
all kinds of pieces and I met a young
girl at everywhere I went on that trip
and we went all the way up to Hanoi and
we went all the way over to Sante and
things like that but as I came back down
I would ask people do you know anybody
who was in the North Vietnamese Army
that were you know fighting for your
country
and I had not ran I had that had a
positive experience until I got to
Marble Mountain
and the girl said sure I do I said
really I said well who is it she said my
grandfather
hold it and her English was better than
mine far better oh yeah and she's she
looked like she was about 16 17 years
old
and I said well is there any chance that
you know we could meet and she said sure
and so she said but you have to talk to
this lady here first and this other lady
was sitting there talking her English
not quite as good but her mission was to
sell me this big
piece of marble
but she had three dolphins swimming out
of it it must weigh a thousand pounds
and it's it stands about five feet tall
and I know my wife okay Miss Donna would
love that so I said well I like to buy
that and so that got me through the door
to get to the guy that was her
grandfather
whoa so she she says okay with this I
said I'll tell you what I'm going to
come back tomorrow she's oh no bye
tonight I said no I'll be back tomorrow
and then we'll go I will the next day I
went out okay well while we're up there
and I'm I've jumped way ahead but
basically what's going to happen is I'm
going to tell you about the story about
the commander
that I met who was the grandfather that
young Vietnamese girl
who was in the mountain the night of the
attack and I've got a picture of that
okay sure of of these guys they've got
letters hanging down to here you know oh
yeah so anyway I'll let you take a
command of the lead here again and go
for it you're there on marble Mountain
this is one of your chores and then at
some point uh you had the mission you
had to go in to the caves I did that was
that was a time when uh
it was just right about the very first
part of November and we were getting we
were getting pot shots from the mountain
uh that faced on the North side and were
getting shots they had sniper shots that
were shooting into the camp when you're
up on the camp we get probed all the
time and uh they would probed they'd
come up and and find out where where we
had our our early warning devices
Claymores and sometimes you'd find it
had been cut or it had been moved okay
or turned around or turned around
exactly and so we had we had heard and
so we went on one of our patrols we went
down the bottom and we found uh on the
South Side of the Mountain okay which is
uh a place where there's a lot of
entrances but they they the Vietnamese
camouflaged it like they built a house
right up against it and there was a
place that they would you could open a
bin like this is this table it's in
front of us they would open a bin and in
that bin there would be rice and things
like it I think oh that's a nice and
bacon had come back when he said no let
me show you something he lifted it up
and it was okay there was grenades there
was all kinds of stuff it was inside the
thing so it's new it was yeah it was and
our holy smoke so then that gave me the
incentive and
I think George might have been with us
on this one but the first one that we
went into
and and uh and George would have been a
better term right because he was a lot
skinnier than I was and uh
but he said no I'm going I said you can
do it you could do it I said okay so I
went in and so you went into a tunnel I
went into well it started out a fairly
large
about opening three opening and then of
course it gets down smaller and smaller
and smaller and as you get into this
thing and wait you went in with a hand
grenade a flashlight and a 45 a 45 okay
so I want to get that straight that's
right that's right and uh two hand
grenades by the way oh two oh you
heavily are okay well if the first one
didn't work I was gonna make sure I had
something to fix trying to get me
but uh anyway we we were you did move in
and you'd call and you'd look and you we
had red lens and if you've ever been in
the woods and you take a white light and
you try to walk through about the only
thing you see in the woods is wherever
that white light is at and so we would
we would sit there and we'd get adjusted
and and the things that I did learn in
AIT training right as to how you would
do you know the visual purple in your
eye as to how you would adjust and so we
were doing that but what we ended up
doing with this this little interpreter
uh
I apologize to him and to you and to
this audience
I can't remember his name but so I
called him Lee and it was it might have
been close to that but I called him Lee
plus not for government works exactly
yes
I watched you guys tear it up in the
king bee thing the other day yeah but I
I I would get with him and he would turn
around to me
and we were close enough there was all
your signals your hand and arm signals
were oh sure we're almost touched and he
would you know put his hand on his mouth
and be quiet listen and then he'd touch
his nose
what do you want me to do what's the
smell
we could we could after I got used to it
it took me about 10 or 15 minutes and I
could then smell where they had been
cooking where they have been smoking and
they were probably no further than
15 20 feet away from me from where we
were at this point that tightened me up
a little bit no kidding yeah that time
yeah because I'm drinking a little bit I
can't just jump up and run right and if
I'm crawdadding backwards you know can
you crawl backwards at a high rate of
speed uh no no I cannot
then or especially now but I I sit there
and uh I I go oh man this is something
so we were back and we made some notes
and we passed it off uh to the S3
section and I said this is this is what
we think is is going to happen and this
is what we smell is and so but of course
when they finally get how they want to
they want to next thing they want to do
is go in and they want to gas all those
tunnels okay so the next time I went in
I went in with a gas mask and they were
thinking all right so
yeah
you're young and dumb and you know oh
yeah oh yeah and so I thought well but I
got in there and I had that gas mask and
I had to get rid of one of the grenades
so I could get the gas mask on one side
I said okay now what if they gas this
thing
okay
and I'm first of all I gotta I got I was
in a position where you had probably be
about no more than four or five inches
above your head so you had to take clear
that put that on clear that mask okay
and so you're carrying the gas mask in
your official government issue gas mask
holder that's it which had one or two
buttons on it you had to open the lid
yes pull it out get it configured and
then strap it over your head yes and
they wanted you to do that in a tunnel
okay very good so like clarify so they
they were talking about they were going
to take at one end of it and then we're
going to flood these tunnels with gas
and so I I kept getting these visions of
rolling waves of gas like water waves
coming in through there and then I could
also see mad crazy animal because we
heard there were animals inside these
things yeah you know all kinds
everything from Tigers to to Giant
kiwandas or whatever the heck it was in
there not to mess in dogs dogs forget
about that yeah yeah that's it so
but we got in and thank goodness they
they somebody from the higher command
dispelled that uh they said no we don't
we don't want the Buddhist uh monks we
didn't want them to fall out on the
ground above the gas Rises up so we came
out and I I was very thankful so that
was my two tunnel rat stories that I
have for you oh my God was that during a
period of time where they also had
talked about maybe trying to blow the
mountain up you the Marines had talked
about and they're going to strap
together like a hundred yards yes of
blocks of C4 yes Towing in and try to
blow up the entire Mountain that's it
yes yeah you remember that that happened
about
December the 12th through the 15th
somewhere in that time frame and we had
a young Lieutenant that was killed up on
the mountain and since I'd had a lot of
experience on the mountain I was one of
the guys that was using marble Mountain
Man the marble Mountain Man like
Marlboro Man but I'm the marble mountain
man so they what they asked was that can
you go over here and do these types of
things and help
researcher we would do all of that
and somehow the the news media got word
of this the marble Mountain was starting
to become a kind of a popular area for
things to be happening in the news media
Walter Cronkite types Were Somehow
showed up they showed up with their
cameras and and uh
after several
uh
discussions close and personal they
decided to leave right we had that F of
B1 where for a while there
um at the bar in the morning the herb
breakfast the joke was okay today whose
turn is it to chase away to reporters
he asked me foreign
and that was what happened that day up
on the mountain and so we were trying to
bring this this body down well what had
happened was is that our commander was
so angry with the fact that he had lost
a guy out there on the mountain
and he and this third Amtrak Commander
uh they had uh maybe gotten together and
you know saluted saluted are dead but
what ended up happening is that this
third Amtrak Commander had called
somebody
from
the Big Air Force Base up on the hill
there in Danang and uh
they
pulled in two deuce and a halfs
and all of these deuce and halves these
these marines folded out their
demolition teams and they pulled these
things and it looked like a rope that
was about two inches wide that connected
these blocks of C4 that looked like they
were two feet by two feet square and it
was it I I to me it looked like it went
a mile but I would say easy 100 yards
they got they was coming off of that
truck and they were lining it up and 10
foot sections okay and what they were
going to do is they said all right they
go we want you to show us where you can
take this in and put this stuff into the
tunnel into the tunnels I said okay I
said but you understand there's somebody
there's only room for either it or year
and I said I'm not seeing in that tunnel
with that I could tell you that
well they we they did they got some into
it and their hold objective was was to
blow this mountain apart period
and I never heard that yeah yeah I
and so again the the higher powers to be
somewhere
from the mayor of Danang to uh McAfee
headquarters in Saigon but the ward got
back stop your Madness explaining on
that that's right no more
so we all came out of that and that's
that's the story on the on the blow the
marble Mountain down oh my god I've
never heard that yeah I love it so
moving on so at some point did you
remain on Sidewinder I knew you got
assigned to a hatch of forces I did I
did I got I got uh I kind of got wounded
up on the mountain okay and thank
goodness well Firefox it was a fire
fight that night came down they had
reversed a couple things on us and I
came down uh
one side of it and there was a small uh
kind of like a tauper type of thing it
blew uh myself and the big chunk of rock
off the side of the mountain and down I
went about 25 feet and landed oh my God
and oh yeah and so the little people
were looking at Maine and they got oh
buku kilo
whereas the people who call me cone
trowel which is water buffalo and so I
said okay and so they went but I finally
got one of the Medics got down stopped
the bleeding or at least put the
pressure on it yeah and then they got a
king bee to come in there to and I'm
thankful for this day that oh my God is
that right the king bee took me off the
mountain and took me up to China Beach
and all that sort of thing and so I was
I was very happy yeah and uh they wanted
to take and send me back to Japan and
all the way and I said no I'm going if
I'm going anywhere I'm going back
to the fob sure so I've stayed in
convalescence up here four or five days
and then I brought me back down I was in
my Recon Hut with bacon who was gone
again okay and Center for Alan Jones for
some reason I remember seeing you at
that time yeah when you were doing a
recoup regroup yep I don't know why or
maybe that was when we came to that by
that time was it January yeah yeah so we
closed fob one yeah our team RT Virginia
came down
and there you are so okay now it's
coming together so I'm I'm now trying to
get back into
the bacon is gone nobody nobody knows
where he's at and I said this is it now
now I'm an experienced guy right from
the tunnel rats to the marble mountain
man I said I need to get on here so I
tried to uh strap hang with some guys
Dave Maurer and Dave Mauer said you know
I love you man you're a good guy you
know what you're doing but blah blah
blah he's but you're just too damn big
oh yeah and he said my little people
don't want nothing to do with you oh no
I said all right Robbie Robinson is it
the same thing yeah and it went on and
uh so then I left from there and I went
up to the hatchet I gave up the position
I passed on the team to Bob Bobby schrag
oh okay Stick Over RT Sidewinder I went
to uh the hatchet force and from the
hatchet Force we ran a couple of BDA
missions that's for a bomb damage
yourself damage right which again you
know the theory is our Air Force go well
Obama and everybody in the grounds could
be Dazed and Confused we just want you
Recon guys just go take a couple
pictures tell us how the bomb damage was
and all the the the enemy troops we
dazing if they won't bother you yeah
nothing further from the truth when you
land through some pissed off NBA troops
here well let me tell you that they were
they came out of the holes like rabbit
dogs
now thank God their aim was all because
they were probably still does these days
yeah okay so at least they were days
exactly but they were shooting and they
were mad and a couple of the birds one
bird took uh took an RPG in the in the
belly it didn't and uh insertion
insertion right we're coming in and uh
so we a couple of us jumped out we
grabbed uh we grabbed one of them and I
think he was dead by the time he got
back
but we're going to throw him in you know
he was probably for some Snuffy he had
no value of Intel at all
and a couple of guys but but whatever
basically got shot out uh I got the deal
yeah the the
Chinooks is what we flew in on oh and uh
okay so we went in and as the weather
was closing in on top of us as well oh
no so air support was limited and so
that was that and then the next
BDA we went in on tour we we didn't go
in for about a week later and it was uh
as accurate as the boys were with the
bombs I think it was the next Valley
over yeah
it wasn't even anywhere close where they
put us
um so we stood on the ground for four or
five days and and uh finally came out
and
and then after that I ended up going I
had an opportunity to uh to go over and
to watch to fly weather fact and to be a
radio operator over.com Phenom and to
help with bright lights and stuff like
that sure and that and non-confer Nam
was in Thailand yes it was an
operational base for the 46 Special
Forces Group yes and what they couldn't
talk about was the sog operation
Operation that went on there so anybody
that came in that was a test Assad when
they when the plane with no markings
would land yep an Air Force truck with
no more markings would back up to it you
get in and when we were there they had
they had a curtain to close so if
anybody looked through the driver's
window you couldn't see the doors are
closed take us over to uh to the sog
headquarters there because it had some
kind of other a knock was signed it just
said something I forget what it was but
yeah then we come in and so welcome to
uh the song basement in Thailand and you
did some weather or in Aura yeah it's
not RNR I mean weather missions oh sorry
I misspoke no kidding yeah oh so then I
spent the time there and I did some
weather fact and I did the other things
and we did a couple of uh
uh a couple of bright lights and I
helped a couple of the Medics go and
pick the teams up and whoever was coming
out but none of them uh the guys that
have been wounded would have been the
little people
um they they're the ones that got hurt
uh but the Americans that were on the
team they were okay and so
that uh so but you had to do a bralette
so you had you were on a brightly you
were strap hanging on a bright lab to go
and help a team that had been well I I
say bright light there was more of a
Medevac and I went in to help the
Medevac okay so you're the chase
medicine well I chase half many there we
go now you got it I was actually helping
a Chase formatic indeed but uh but we
went in we went in on the Jolly grains
right so when they came in uh they had
more air assets at nkp uh than they did
at other parts of across the fence back
particularly when the weather was sucked
in so nothing could launch from Vietnam
and you're and launching from nkp or
udon you born it was the only way in
that's right to get to our people on the
ground yeah and so you're a part of that
yeah wow so I I was fortunate enough to
be there uh
when the when the men landed on the moon
right now how would they have the radio
on and we all came in and and uh you
know we had a glass of water Coke beer
whatever it was we had and we tipped our
glasses and thought that was the coolest
thing since lunch spread so indeed yeah
and
fairly much that was the the tour uh for
Vietnam I packed all that up and came
back and yeah
yeah well what went on and uh went back
to college and finished that and then
went to uh uh
became I was part of an or excuse me
before I went into thing I was part of
in junior college boys Junior College I
had I was part of the 116th ordinance in
Idaho
and uh yeah I was a National Guard unit
and and then of course my dad said I
thought about I'm joining I've had it I
said as soon as I'm finished with school
I'm going to go in he said no whatever
you do don't go airborne and don't go to
Special Forces and I said oh okay I had
met a recruiter already by that time out
there and this guy super guy and uh
anyway anyway long story made sure I
ended up I don't go back to school there
um and then in 73 I I was
inactive reserve active reserve right
and then I for a total of six years of
service exactly and then I went back in
73 I went back on active duty again
and I was trying to get back to Vietnam
but they were shutting it down right and
I said oh man so you went back to active
duty where yeah I went well this is a
funny story of course that ties into
spider parks
yeah well I ended up going to four-door
and in Fort orders what I ended up in
Fort Ord was it because there's a
special uh replacement company that
takes active duty guys and came back
here well I came back in at the original
rank I got out as as an E5 and they said
we're going to take and put you in a
program that is that is being stunned up
right now for for God's like yourself
and we're going to take him we're going
to send you Aid or a OCS or B we'll send
you to a new special warrant program
that's being developed I said okay
so when I got the Fort Ord
everything was lost nobody even knew
anything about any of my records or
nothing and I swear I stayed in a
holding company and I'm down there and I
thought
hey what's going on here it also yeah
I'll try to see it come out no the the
other thing you're just going back
settle down did you got a choice either
you can get out we'll give you a
discharge and go whatever you want to do
or he went I was like well I'm not doing
much I'll just get in shape so I ended
up doing that started running and doing
some things like that and so they
thought why don't you just why don't you
just go back through basic training
again no I said wait a minute you're
trying I said yeah that's it I said what
the hell back to basic training again
okay now I'm in basic training now these
guys found out that I was who I was
and they said oh okay well we need some
instructors and we and they found out oh
have you ever shot the law I said yeah a
couple times I said well why don't you
be our peer law instructor out on the
Range
here I am saying here in basic training
I but this time I was running this
platoon that I had that yes the
instructors had walked away and you're
the only guy with the CIB on well I
didn't have anything I was still sterile
I was clandestine at that point but that
but some people knew who I was sure yeah
yeah and so then it was about the second
or third third week I think into it the
instructors would come to me and say
hey
why don't you come with us or let's play
some football
oh I said really I said yeah we hear
that you played football in college I
said yeah I said okay so I'm out there
at night okay today I'm with the guys at
night I go back in I said what about the
guys there don't worry about that we'll
have CQ we'll keep an eye on them for
you
I'm out there playing football and then
I'm lined up I'm on the defense and I'm
sitting there I'm digging in I'm getting
ready to to go after the quarterback and
I hear this voice at quarterback
spider oh my god spider was out at the
Presidio going through language school
right and he's out there playing
football and I stood up and I said you
sure are a pretty mother you know
he looks he goes what are you doing here
with no hair
I don't have everything yeah and I've
got a picture of this that you should
see it anyway I've graduated about
another week or so after that and uh
they
they came out and so spider walks out I
didn't have I still didn't have any
orders spider walk sat on a Prayer field
takes off that hat has my beret okay
he said this is it he says first chance
you get get some boots on and blouse
them busted okay he was an E7 then yeah
and so I said okay I'll do it and I got
a picture of us standing there side by
side now I've got my stuff on my chest
right oh yeah everything yeah and so
after that I said well I'm not sure
what's going to happen as far as me
getting back to brag he said Oh you mean
this set of orders right here no yeah
yeah oh yeah so they said they sent me I
already got fifth group Third Battalion
back in there and I showed up and I
reported in wow that's yeah and by that
time fifth group was back at Bragg back
at Brag indeed yeah and so then we did a
few quick things and I just got on the
same
perpetual motion of a Recon man and
everything was moving very rapidly I was
I got assigned a scuba School graduated
came back so how long was school bus
school back then I think it was like six
weeks and Chris what one of the unknown
least publicized aspects of Special
Forces Green Beret training is scuba
school yes because that school
is tough yeah in fact I knew that
besides medical training I knew the
scuba school with my bad ears is one
place I never wanted to be
so you down here you graduated so just
give us a little bit of a feel what that
Scuba schools like what they put you
through in terms of trying to drown you
as part of your training oh they do they
enjoy it too indeed oh I'm trying to I I
think they were rejects from the Navy
course or something because of the
instructors you know so some old seals
down there
exactly if you were serious about your
training
they uh they they push you pretty hard
yeah they've been long hours night
training Night Swimming uh and they're
just and runs long runs uh 12 15 Mile
runs and uh long swim
swims and uh probably one of the better
conditioning that I was by the time I
finished that it sure it was very good
yeah it's Dwayne is any part of that
training include submarine training not
the introduction so no but it did not
that's right that's right that's that's
the next thing and that they they
actually mentioned it and they talk
about you know
hyperbaric chambers and how you you do
your those sorts of things
they mentioned that and but as you and
your interest was tweaked oh yes or as I
was I was on that fast track absolutely
they get back to brag and then uh next
thing I know uh there is no NCO in the
scuba Locker and guess where I went for
fifth group the fifth group at Fort
Bragg okay yeah yeah so I'm I'm in there
and I'm looking at all that simple first
of all you need equipment so the next
thing I know I'm out in California
at U.S divers headquarters okay out here
yeah okay
buying new equipment then I go to AMF
Boyd uh I I meet some legendary Navy
guys seals and get there working for AMF
for it at that time uh Jocko will
probably know a few of the names when I
mention them to him indeed but
um
when that I came back and when I came
back then
um
they they said well we need somebody for
preschool I said well
I am a dive instructor you know civilian
they said oh okay
well why don't you do the preschool but
that way we won't lose you to Key West
so I I should have known then that my my
latitude okay yeah was limited as to
which way I could go left or right I
said okay so then we started doing
pre-scuba and then off the preschooler
somebody said oh you were in Germany so
did I said yes did you ever go down in
Bavaria I said yeah I said I used to
swim all the time but I can't say I'd
say you know I'm saying oh really oh you
speak German and I paused and I went
well let's just that I learned from my
Gabriel days to limit you know that I
said well I I can say hello and goodbye
and maybe I can order a beer they go
perfect you're just the man we need for
our Scout swimming program
I happen to meet one of the legendary
Scout swimmers from Sweden Barney
Nielsen and Barney Nielsen was in the
movie The Green Beret and he was on the
uh on the Gabriel team that they they
demoed that were all actually Green
Berets in that movie
Barney and I became good friends and
Barney came over and and worked with me
and we set up the Scout swimming program
and all of a sudden now I became a guru
in Scout swimming no you say Scout this
is like the Scout in the military sense
of going out for a Recon early
pre-mission Recon in this case it would
be Aqua yeah related to water type Recon
as a scout imagine this if you will this
is this is a Twilight Zone thing imagine
that you walk up to the edge of water
and you're looking out at the ocean and
it's flat calm indeed and yet you look
out there and you see some debris
floating in that water and it is maybe
it's it's seaweed maybe it's whatever
then you see some air bubbles perhaps
this is before the new rebreather these
guys are Scout swimmers they will come
in and they will do what's known as a
horizon insertion indeed they will come
in where you're like about three to four
miles offshore off three or four miles
now miles and they will they will exit
The Craft and they will swim in
not making one bit of Ripple and as they
get in and they'll they'll time it with
the tides and as they get close to where
they're going to do the tides will drift
them right into Shore really and they're
and they're camo'd up they may have
seaweed that they can collect along the
way or they'll look like a floating log
any number of things what that is the
Scout swimmer program no kidding but let
me tell you something if you've laid in
that water as long as I have like 12 14
hours
you're like a prune coming out of a jar
that's right
so welcome to the scalp program oh yeah
so now I had some experience in that and
then all of a sudden the the locker
wasn't busy enough with Scout swimming
and Scuba but then I inherited okay yeah
the rubber boats the art the rb15s
indeed and the motors that went with it
I said oh okay well I knew a little bit
about
boats and I know a little bit about
Motors but I didn't know enough about
what I needed to know
so one of the commanders come in and
says well why don't you try to fix that
I said well I would if I could
and I could if I knew what to do and if
I had the right tools they said well
where you need that I said I need to go
to school
I said okay
so I got on a set of orders I show up in
Waukegan Illinois which is where the
Johnson outboard motor school is that
was our 35 horses at that time I show up
there and stand and behold is the
legendary the infamous okay yes indeed
Walt sheer mate no well and I went
through Johnson outboard motor for
school and Stevens Electronics course
Advanced okay
I won't go into the particulars of this
but let me tell you
there's a reason Walt shumate is a
legend indeed that's right and he he
showed the old young guy
how to drink a beer
we had a good time we came back from
that and just give us a little bit of
Watts history prior to your running into
him there yeah because he had been in
nam several tours at least one was SOG
yes and of course he was up Legend in in
our the scuba training programs and the
combat diver programs later yes and this
is you're meeting him there at in the
capacity that I was in oh my God
the way we became
friends and uh
the the next thing after that when I
came back is that uh it wasn't busy
enough yet and the locker so they said
well
the Battalion is now going to go and
we're going to do some winter Warfare
training oh well when I first came back
something I left out just a moment ago
when I first came back
all right yeah
I was assigned the Third Battalion to go
to Camp Drum New York ooh I was a winter
Warfare instructor because somebody had
heard that when I was in college in
Idaho that I had been on the ski Patrol
I said yeah I said well that's great
you're just the man we're looking for
well I had
although I've skied and I was fairly
proficient at it
I had never seen white star skis that
long and made of wood
and oh no wearing yeah I'm wearing the
the big white jungle boots or not jungle
but jungle the junk bunny winter boots
yes big white
insulated Arctic boots yeah that's it
that you would wear
so anyway
when I got that I got that I did all
that and so in in the training I got up
there and I got familiar with it again
and mastered it pretty quick
and I'm sending Aaron all of a sudden
the 82nd Airborne Division shows up
I am their primary instructor okay young
E5 sitting there looking at these guys
and so I said okay but the first thing I
want I got them online about so first
thing I'm going to do I said I want you
to all okay I'll show them how to turn
walk in this guy's turn around and face
in that direction when they did I walked
around I said now anytime that I can get
the snow out of your eyes you can see me
a little bit better
so
that statement and that statement along
there was two generals in that class in
that thing really and I had
letter upon letter upon letter of
recommendation okay they came down
through the channels and I'm trying to
think of the general of the center at
that time and if somebody can remember
his name well he wasn't as good as you
were so anyways anyway what he what they
did is that hey this this guy's walk on
water winter winter Warfare instructor
no oh yeah so now I've now I've I am now
okay the winter Warfare instructor and
also whatever whatever skis that we had
with fifth Special Forces I had no idea
that that was part of our AO our
assignment
I'm now getting all this old school
stuff that's in there from Chippewa
Boots to now oh
you know about Chippewa well good now
you'll become the mountaineering
instructor as well what so I had pitons
and Hammers and and climbing and ropes
and you name it I had it I was doing
that and I was saying to somebody
earlier and I said you know I had a 365
days in a year yeah I was gone 360.
was gone I mean TDY you name it oh my
God
oh my God so from that
um
we
we started doing
uh going back to a question you had
asked earlier about submarines yes that
was that was that your old water Locker
details right right well uh I said okay
we need somebody to go with us to help
set this thing up and since you're the
guy that seems to have a little bit more
about that and what rb15 and what you're
going to set up was
what submarines yes submarine training
so I said okay so we ended up going with
the go-to team at that time was was uh a
a team charge at legendary Sante Raider
jockovinko oh of course John cabenco
that's all since I had an MOS that I had
two SF well two and a half
Moses he didn't have a scuba person okay
on his team okay but he needed one his
team was a scuba team
so every now and then I'd get the
bidding to go with it well they were a
high speed team and there's no nonsense
oh no no
he was one Kick-Ass oh yeah oh yeah and
him and uh there was always competition
Andre Smith is another one that was in
there Andre had another team and then
all the teams would be competing well
anytime somebody needed something that
had they needed an echo okay right or a
Bravo which I was also or a half of uh
mathematic I got assigned to him I was
tedious I was a strap hanger for that
group so
um
so in this case you're getting ready for
a serious submarine training of which
you knew little at that time yeah but go
on Ron yeah it was it was it was amazing
time uh and I kept thinking at least if
I just could go back to Recon company
yeah no kidding yeah
so we did we did a lot of winter Warfare
training we did some stuff out in Idaho
and Alaska and Eskimo Scout teams and
but then you did get back don't walk
away from the submarines oh oh yeah
please
um yeah we did we we got we got to do
that type of training and so by then
were you still dealing with Diesels or
by that point were they beginning to
phase in your training with upgraded
submarines up to nuclear perhaps oh good
point we decommissioned uh
we went to Key West to do their training
on the last diesel submarine at that
point in time right and we took it out
and we Dove it and we took it down to
Guantanamo Bay and we got out there and
we did some uh underwater explosive
training with it and some horrendous
looking pictures I'll show you sometime
but
they when we did that we we
decommissioned that submarine and doing
lock-in lockouts uh putting rubber boats
out and all that type of thing and
the
uh
that submarine and I can't remember what
that sale was
the name it'll come to me I'm sure
it was it was the last one
decommissioned and our government sold
it to the Falkland government
and when the Falcon war broke out the
British shank it either by accident or a
person I don't know what happened but
that submarine is at the bottom of the
city down there someplace the Admiral
the British royalties is exactly this
thing is so old it's not even of use to
us but you guys trained on what other
aspect to the uh the old diesel sub that
you preferred over to more modern
substance well there was for us larger
than average
scuba guys okay that old diesel sub
trunk was much bigger okay yeah you
could get you could easily get Five Guys
inside that and still be tight but still
and for our listeners they're not
familiar with either army or navy water
issues the trunk is that is the lockout
chamber there we go uh imagine climbing
into uh
a round washer through the hole and then
getting five you know uh Five Guys
inside that completely your breathing
apparatus that's right well there's that
it comes out of out of the wall of that
little washing machine and you're inside
there and then there's one big hole
that's like 30 inches in diameter that
leads out to the open ocean and uh so
when you when you get inside this then
they'll shut the main hatch or they'll
dog the hatch as they say and when they
do that they'll open the blow which is
okay which allows some pressure air
pressure inside it but then they'll
flood the trunk and when they flood the
trunk that kind of tightens you up a
little bit because now the water is now
rising up rising up at your chest now
it's up to your chin now it's right up
to the bottom of your lip and then
you're not sucking oxygen or air from
the little too just a little tube you
sit there a little little regulator you
put that in your mouth and the night the
breathing amazingly gets uh
a lot quicker as a pucker Factor that's
a poker Factor that's right indeed and
so they then they then will take they'll
flood the trunk it's up above your head
and above that that round 30 inch tube
that that's what they're doing is
they're going to equalize the inside
pressure to the outside pressure well
they'll open that pressure up
okay the tube opens and it kind of looks
like something you've seen the movie the
guys go in that tube and you come out
the other tube and now you're and the
old diesel Subs you were below deck that
a super structure above that so you
would get out there and you'd get
everybody together and then from that
point uh
you could take and put your gear on
usually it was and the gear was strapped
to the deck it's strapped to the deck
yeah and then you would reach up and
you'd grab it and put it on and and uh
through all the training and then you
would either uh come to the surface or
stay stay with as the as the submarine
is moving in a forward but it always has
to be moving as it's moving in the
forward position you would swim on the
trunk line that would go to the top of
that and if you're going to exit you'd
have to go up because you can't go up
too fast
and you would get up close to the top
where the the Periscope you know would
normally break water right at that point
on a certain signal we would break free
left and right of the con and it would
pass right in front of you really I'm
going to tell you something there's
nothing nothing so amazing as that trunk
passing past you one half of the teams
on one side the other half of the team's
on the other and as they go past you
we're in crystal clear
water that is Bluer Than Blue and as
that submarine goes back solid black
right behind that okay great big con is
a big beautiful American flag moving
underwater no oh my God it is it sounds
cool to this moment it sends chills up
by it yeah I like yeah I can't imagine
unbelievable wow
and then I watched it that particular
moment I wasn't odd that I heard a clunk
and then one of the guys had his knife
had fallen out of out of his Scabbard on
his leg and you could watch the glint of
the of the Sun as it hit the blade as it
disappeared
into two thousand feet of water it just
disappeared forever
but then you looked up and realized wow
I'm really out here in the ocean and
then you looked around and then you
looked up
and in the very very close proximity was
a school of about 25 Hammerheads no yeah
but at first you just look it's like a
fire truck yeah you go holy smoke it's a
and then you go and then the Curiosity
then you want to go over and swim with
them you know for whatever reason oh
we're Hammerheads but oh yeah whatever
it is
sharks exactly and so anyway that that's
that's my that's my submarine story now
the submarine store for the nuclear
submarine yeah
a lot tighter smaller trunk okay
and when this open tube when it opens it
opens into the open ocean okay so when
you come out of that you better have
your faculties together and be able to
come in they have a line that runs along
and you either have to snap into it or
get a real good grip on it so you can
come back and then put your gear on
while you're underwater
most of those most of those that we did
uh we would go out of like Groton
Connecticut
and you'd go out to see and you'd link
up with the destroyer and that would be
you know or
some type of big type of Battleship like
that or I'll probably send all the
things to cruise you guys will probably
just hit me upside to here when Jocko
gets here what are boats they're big
boats some have guns some don't that's
right these didn't have sales well I can
tell you that so
but Marine Corps transportation service
that's right indeed
because we get some green berries
sneaking in there for a little train so
by this time would that be official
combat diver training yes that's right
and that all of that they'd go through
extensive training and then they'd go
through extensive what they call trunk
training uh the trunk training would be
Towers uh Escape Towers where you would
lock out at the bottom of a hundred feet
and then you would have to ascend to the
surface on a single breath of air and in
a hundred feet of water and 100 feet no
what about bends no no there's no bins
okay you guys that's not allowed that's
not
yeah you hope but what they do is that
when they take that uh as you ascend
that you would go back up yeah the the
on one breath on one breath and you take
a breath and then you'll go back up uh
and then there's safety divers that stay
with the divers and makes his ascend it
goes up and they can do that once then
they also have something called the
sinking we used to be called the sinking
hoods it's a hood that goes over your
head and they would do this from a
little bit deeper uh water and and a
little bit colder type of climate and
it's an Escape mechanism that they would
say ho ho ho that would be like blow and
go but this is ho ho ho ho ho ho not to
be confused yeah and uh don't don't get
it confused whatever indeed yeah oh my
God but that's that is the the extent of
those two types of submarines that I've
had exposure to and working with and my
my position in the dive lockers the
ncoic of of that facility so why are you
doing Mountain training
and other winter training right you're
still okay yeah
that's right
and and in the meantime I was trying to
train up some trainers right I need help
I need help
and so uh we did and we did some really
cool stuff I have this skiing uh I ended
up later on I became involved with
Natick Laboratories and Natick
Laboratories we designed uh one of the
very I'm jumping from submarines to snow
skiing now indeed and we designed one of
the very first new 180 centimeter skis
that was designed for mountaineering
with Chippewa boots or a boot that would
be similar to Chippewa that would be
more upper collar so you could do more
downhill type skiing as opposed to cross
country right that way you could do both
you could do both we were designing
bindings at that time that would have
the heel of capability that could that
you could do your skating with as far as
the you know the kick and glide that's
what they talked about right because
they the winter training is so critical
because there's so many areas of
operations around the world yes where
Winter training is a critical element
yes that we have to train and be able to
train in business troops how to mount
near prepare for war and self-defense
yes but that's all part of this training
which is so different from
being underwater I know you're there of
the art at the time well you know from
the marble mountain man
here I am that's a long swim brother oh
it's a long swim
I was I was fortunate though to be part
of these things and didn't make it but
the theater of operation would be tenth
group that you would think as far as the
winter Warfare right and the types of
things that they would do but and they
have been involved in the Cold War for
years out of Germany yes exactly you had
to be ready for anything across the
fence Behind Enemy Lines in the
mountains yes and that's
you know I was fortunate to have some
little bit of input to help out for
whatever little teams there were some
some teams that were they would then
start becoming ad hoc to a 10th group
team for example right in the theater of
operation and I think you see a lot more
of that now like in Afghanistan and Iraq
where teams from the third group uh
their AO might be Africa for example but
yet you'll see them in South America or
you've seen guys from the seventh group
and there might be South America Central
America but you might have seen them in
20-year War every group that used to
have special areas in the world yeah all
of which were Trend through either
Afghanistan or Iraq at one time there
you go Anthony while they had they're
still their basic jurisdiction or
country that each group was attached to
like I said Africa South America Asia
indeed wow
so in our in my story of back to now yes
indeed all right
um I think that that I've been very
fortunate uh
to have been with
uh the men okay
of yesteryear okay my SOG brother indeed
and uh and then as I move forward
um into what was happening I I ended up
going into the civilian Side of
Everything
which would be into the department of
energy and Department of Defense so what
would be your time frame Ron
oh let's see at the survived basic
training for the second time you go in
you do your Mountain training out of the
world exactly well thank you I guess I
need to put closure to that don't I I I
think that was wrapped up about 1981 and
then I rotated out of that and rotated
over to uh
the civilian side of the house okay
right and
my dad uh was then still living in Idaho
no no my dad actually my dad's retired
uh military and uh World War II guy that
fought in the Illusions and stuff like
that
and he's the one told me don't go don't
go don't go
and uh so anyway we we ended up in so he
I said what do you want to do I said he
said why don't you come and work with me
and he says and I'll get you a job at
Sharon Harris nuclear power plant whoa
and I said oh okay and uh he said uh
what do you want to do I said let's
let's start out with something simple
see well what just be a labor I said
okay
or somehow it's like
you know becoming a
ski Guru somebody could oh this guy's
got some leadership skills here we're
going to make you a foreman okay so when
I became a labor foreman and then I
ended up becoming a labor superintendent
and then they they said okay well we
need you and some training capacity
because I'll say you've got background
and training so we're going to send you
over to uh a brand new stand-up stand
this operation up as the largest
aluminum Rolling Mill okay in the world
and you're going to be the training
manager slash director for this for
Daniels International okay it's like
brown and root or Daniel but Daniel's
International I said okay
so they sent me over there and it's in
Russellville Kentucky okay which is just
up from
what's that little place in Kentucky
with a Ford in it oh yeah Campbell soup
or something like that yeah yeah so I
went up there and we stood that up okay
and we stood that up and got that all
done and very very successful probably
excuse my total ignorance but why would
he need a big security program for an
aluminum rolling well it was
I could see where you can bring it in
but I
I was not in the security capacity at
that time oh okay no this was just as a
director of training okay to stand up
these things so what I did was is to set
up the stand up the programs and they
had something called best bests it's
basic entry skills training okay and in
that uh they had all of their crafts
they had uh welding they had Plumbing
they had uh
uh
carpentry blueprint yeah okay they had
carpentry sure they had uh they had
steel uh
anything you can build with well
anything heavy duty construction sure
and so what we did is we went in and we
set the thing up as to where it would be
similar to what an ATM would do is you'd
go into a country you get the people you
recruit them you train them in the
different skill sets and that's what I
did I just managed that wow and set them
up yeah did very well uh I became a
colonel at that point
and I think that's where I was trying to
okay
an honorary position that they gave to
indeed that there's some things I forget
about the Kentucky tradition oh yes yes
indeed yeah yeah so anyway they uh
Colonel Owens does have a nice ring to
it though it does it does
hmm
but my wife won't recognize it you know
I I think that what happened was there
with the the training as we developed
from there which will tie back into the
security
was that
they needed some assistance in another
part of the world called the Middle East
and so at that point they wanted
somebody to come over to help so now
we're into the 90s yes we're into the
90s yes sir and thank you and so now
they wanted to
um
they wanted somebody to come over and
help establish a training program
which would be kind of like a train the
trainer program and that program would
be to replace
expats in a country and by doing so what
they ended up doing was that they took
the individuals
that were in country say for example you
were in there working in security or you
were in there working as a
superintendent of of uh building tables
whatever whatever the job may be
and my job would be to take one of the
Saudis or the yeamans or whoever it may
be of Arabic or whatever nationality
they may be but uh
they wanted us to train them to take
that place of the expat
The American or the British or whoever
it may be so here in the desert we're in
the had a great opportunity with all
your winter Mountain training yeah and
your combat diver training in the desert
yes oh very good I just want to make
sure it was clear but as you will see
the Gap closes as it closes oh yes well
the first big assignment was in a place
called uh
oh well I'm having a moment here I'll
get this in the Middle East so you're
moving on yeah yeah it is the Saudi
Arabia right around there yes yes
um
anyway I'm I'm and the name will come
here in just a second but what ends up
happening was is that as I go into this
country we set it up
and but there's Riyadh which is on the
one side
uh almost almost had it and bias time
Desert Storm Desert Shield already
passed no they have not that was this
was before that okay right so while I'm
there if we're setting up these programs
um
they are in the position of looking at
water uh filtration plants
um now the company is called Dela cell
de la cell is is a is a German company
and what they want to do is they want to
translate from German to English and
English to Arabic okay and we have to
take him and put that into a format of
training and that's everything from
teaching someone from the basic as a
okay right or a regular guy just like I
did when I went to work at the Sharon
Harris nuclear plant all the way up to
an engineer type
so my job was to develop the training
programs for that and then I try and
helped translate from one language to
another if it became too difficult then
obviously I would either go to the
Internet or I would I would hire an
advanced interpreter to sit down and
work with us well the internet was still
kind of new then yes but most of these
places had pretty good size internets
okay okay because it was developed at
the corporate level right yeah and I
don't so much as think of it as Internet
at that point like we know it today
correct it was more
uh it was more machines that had so much
uh so much
data that you could go back and then
would refer
a lot like internet as we think of it
but but slower okay along those lines
and a lot bigger machines a lot oh yes
much better A lot bigger I um I
apologize for not be able to remember
the name
it it's the largest city in Saudi Arabia
and it's right on the coast
um that's right it's a big city thought
everybody we're moving right on this oh
yeah yeah so anyway we got there uh
and then after that uh that job ended
um then I came back
and the
what was what year was that
we're in the 90s I think yeah because by
that time then there was Desert Storm
Desert Shield the invasion of Kuwait
yeah I was I wasn't in the country when
that happened but it all happened so it
helps you with the time frames well
because also you've had over your
lifetime you've kept some of your
relations with the scuba diving training
down on the Florida Keys well I did and
in addition to that I also well I was
there working all in your spirits well I
got Jeddah yeah that was on Jetta I
should have known me too
but while we were there I met several
different uh contractors that were there
and also uh people that wanted scuba
diving training
so I said well if you could give me some
equipment they said well we know just
the guy and so they're taking me
downtown okay and there's a guy who's
Arabic and he goes yes
he said you teach I said yes this is
what he said here's the keys to the shop
you can run it just when you're done he
says come back he says whatever money
you make just put it in his can over
here and don't worry about it
really I mean I had talked to him that
long
I didn't I don't even know his name he
didn't know my name but he knew that I
was going to start I have my card that's
my car yeah he was so excited that there
was somebody there that could teach you
so I started teaching when I wasn't
working during the day yeah doing the
normal things I was doing I would go
there and teach at night I made more
money at night than I made on the
contract that I was working over there
unbelievable
the
the German airline company
I can't think of the name of that right
now the biggest one that they've got but
they had they had little hubs inside of
Saudi Arabia and you would live in these
compounds and I would go if they had
their own pools they had everything just
go in there and then teach the only
thing that you couldn't do really in the
country you had to be very careful it
was drinking you couldn't be caught
drinking
oh my so
being the clandestine guy that I am and
going back and falling in indeed
somebody found out one of those German
guys found out that I knew something
about boats that I knew something about
Motors that I knew something about
diving and also found out that I was in
Special Forces and he said
I need you to help me
I said okay
and why not we go out on the coast
south of Jeddah okay
this is getting kind of scary indeed get
out there all of a sudden a boat appears
so guys get off but the boat it's
already got the motor on the back of it
he's all right get in where we're going
don't worry about I'll show you when we
get there
off the shore we go what about two miles
okay yeah
he's got a dip on her he says what do
you think what that's that's a that's a
little bit of a nose coming up it's
about 60 70 feet he said perfect
do you think we can catch up with an
anchor I said well yeah possibly I said
if one of us gets in and goes down they
said we can put the anchor on it
okay
so he tells this guy he says tell me
when you want to be going to work so
he's drifting I said now in the water he
goes down
who hooks up he comes back up to things
that we're hooked now we're we're into
about
three knots four knots of course that
boat is starting to plane up a little
bit on the nose yeah so I'm thinking oh
this is good maybe we're just going to
do some spear fishing at night okay yeah
but I didn't see any spear guns
saw a bunch of bags and stuff like that
so we're sitting there sitting there so
like he said just relax okay so it's
gonna be a few minutes he says I'll tell
you what's happening in a couple of
minutes that's okay
you're always the last time off in the
distance I can hear this
it's getting louder yeah
and it is a freighter that's coming a
freighter a freighter as freighter's
coming straight
he's got some secret light he's blinking
you know that sounded more like a
tugboat yes yes but it would but but it
wasn't
I think it was the cylinder a
one-cylinder type of thing
he's coming
this guy's flashing light he's all right
everybody get your gear on get ready I
was okay
so that's it he's coming he's coming
he's coming and this thing oh this
thing will run over the top of us here
come this thing
he comes with about 20 feet of us
as he goes by off the side of this thing
comes a great big Conex container
down it goes
let's go get it
go get what
the hell's going on come on you can do
it down we go he's got these bags that
you put fish in and things yeah yeah
we'll get out of the bottom
doors up it's full of liquor
oh my God
full of liquor
so
we load this thing up back we go okay
he's got to make about like 15
trips to go back out to the city get it
off oh we got to get it all so he gets
back there and he says all right
he said I'm glad you were here you
really helped out he says it's just you
take a bottle of this and take that home
with you and he says we'll get together
and I'll I'll give you something else
very special you know in a day or two I
said great I said but don't call me in a
day or two I said I was never here okay
because if you get caught with any kind
of liquor over there oh they can chop
your hands off they can get home oh yeah
it was not pretty
so that kind of clanned us on operation
kind of moved itself into back to now
type of thing yes indeed yes and then
after after that I came back okay yes
and the contract that ended over there
and so then
I was notified by my good friends and
special forces that they needed some
help
and that was up in Idaho to stand up the
very first Idaho energy National
Laboratory
SWAT team
anti-terrorist system slash yeah very
first one
so off to Idaho I went
and uh I'll link up with a couple guys
that were former Delta operators okay
and of course you know the guy that's
the seal guy you know yeah he'll want to
know watch him he'll I guarantee he'll
be one of the sake of Rights shut down
yeah what was his name was it
anyway we stepped up the very first team
we developed the program for him up in
Idaho and uh that was it and so it was
back to now again because John and I had
been on the same teams back at Bragg
yeah okay and John had went on to Delta
and stood it up
um so it was it was it was good there's
another guy uh Wade ishimoto that's
inside this thing here he and John were
close friends yes okay so the circle
that I ran in was never ending it was
always touching all the way around from
Vietnam to where we are right now
indeed I did I did the thing I stood
that up we did the program uh
we had everything we had our own
helicopter Bill brand new bill 222
really we we had all mp5s we had all
high speed uh we had brownie High Powers
all brand new uh
all of our vests handmade we had sewers
that would come into everything that we
did was new our program was new and the
department of energy sponsored every bit
of it and it was highly highly
classified
not unlike SOG indeed so anyway it was
it was a very interesting and a very
great time as far as the development of
an individual from then to where we are
I stayed in that program uh up until
they we put the final class through and
graduated
great group of individuals very very
good and so there was job offers out on
the market for me at this time within
the department of energy Circle and I
said goodbye to everybody and my bride
and I went back to Florida but in route
okay in route in route we were coming
right down through Las Vegas and it just
so happened that one of the contractors
that was in he said why don't you come
out here and work for me
for a few days
he said we'll put you up in a hotel here
we'll say okay so we went out to the
Nevada test site and we did some work
out there
and it was it was good
then they tried to hire me to come to
their uh
where's John Wayne Airport at
in uh or Orange County Orange County yes
or in Orange County their their
headquarters they were the former
chief of police and SWAT team commanders
for LAPD wow and uh and so we became
good friends I became really good
friends with their one of their their
guys named Ron Corbin uh oh sure I
remember meeting you yeah yeah and I
have a book for you he's going to give
to you all right that's okay and uh he's
uh he's quite the guy he's quite the guy
but we became good friends
and over the years we would work at
different places and from there from
Florida I went back and I would work
Lawrence Livermore
um
Savannah River
uh and then we worked the department of
energy petroleum sites from New Orleans
all the way over to Brownsville Texas
all the stuff that's buried in the
ground wow we developed their their
protection programs were there and
trained their guys with that
uh
and
and that
that went on for almost 10 years and
then all of a sudden
it was decided by the higher people that
we don't have a terrorist problem
we don't have a we don't have a threat
but really what was happening was is
that
they were unable to get their heads
wrapped around whether from the
political standpoint they were not able
to grasp the direction that they really
needed to go in which was you know a
better threat of assessment
the better types of things that we would
do so what year is this this is all
before 9 11. it's before 9 11. I was
working with that group again and I was
up in New York City
and I became from the marble mountain
man I became a Wall Street was
[Laughter]
we were doing threat assessments for all
of the the high-speed uh
different uh
Drexel Burnham and Lambert
citicorp Citibank all the investment
groups that are in there on Wall Street
and we worked with them to come in to
find what type of
um shortages that they had what type of
uh
shortages in in the sense of did they
have enough training did they have the
right security that they have the right
security cameras they had the right kind
of doors did they have listening devices
did they have ways to detect if their
offices were bugged
ah
excuse me I had the opportunity
to work with some of the brightest and
best of all of our national agencies we
had two station Chiefs that I had I had
worked with I had State Department guys
that I was working with and all of them
had all vast experience
so I again was on a fast track down
moving in the direction where we're
going
um we worked out for a long period of
time as well
and then again at the very end of this
one contract we were asked to come over
to
a thing called the Twin Towers no and we
were asked to take a look at
these the condensation chief
wanted me and about six others to come
in to look at their physical security
and take a look at just if there's a
cursory we weren't getting paid for we
just volunteered it yeah sure we'll be
happy to
we had done very well financially for
the for the things we were there
and what was interesting about this is
that as we went into it it became so
blatantly obvious that these were the
problems that we picked out
so we hand wrote on a piece of paper
those types of things and we handed it
to them we didn't spending more in six
hours doing the whole thing it didn't
take that long
okay oh yeah this is before they had the
first bombing in the in the garage are
you stand you're right on it I it was
two days no two days we left yeah I was
back in North Carolina
it happened
I like to fill out
I picked up the phone and called this
guy who
had hired me to do that
and he said Big O he said let me tell
you something
that rip because it was came out of our
Playbook we picked hand-picked
everything plus some a lot more that
they could have done and one of them was
to do exactly what they did
exactly no yeah and so what ended up
happening was is that now we have you
know you know the background yeah yeah
oh my God so